People are starving,
they may not know it because they're
being fed mass produced garbage,
the packaging,
it's colorful and it's loud,
but it's being produced in the same
factories that make pop tarts and ipads
by people sitting around thinking,
what can we do to get people to buy more
of these and they're very good at their
jobs,
but that's what it is you're getting
because that's what they're making.
They're selling you something and the
world is built on this.
Now politics and government are built on
this.
Corporations are built on this.
Interpersonal relationships are built on
this and we're starving all of us and
we're killing each other and we're
hitting each other and we're calling
each other liars and evil because it's
all become marketing and we want to win
because we're lonely and empty and
scared and we're led to believe.
Winning will change all that,
but there is no winning.
What can be done?
Say who you are,
really say it in your life and in your
work.
Tell someone out there who has lost
someone not yet born.
Someone who won't be born for 500 years.
You're writing will be a record of your
time.
It can't help but be,
but more importantly,
if you're honest about who you are,
you'll help that person be less lonely
in their word because that person will
recognize him or herself in you and that
will give them hope and it's done so for
me and I have to keep rediscovering it.
It's profound importance in my life.
Give that to the world rather than
selling something to the world.
Don't allow yourself to be tricked into
thinking that the way things are is the
way the world must work and that in the
end,
selling is what everyone must do.
Try not to the world needs you.
It doesn't need you at a party.
Having read a book about how to appear
smart at parties.
These books exist and they're
attempting,
but resist falling into that trap world
needs you at the party starting real
conversations saying,
I don't know,
being kind.